hey I'm in Tran and I'm joined by Daniel
Hines hey how you doing I'm good how are
you I'm well thanks Cole and we're here
checking out the siege which is it's a
game on Steam early access and it's all
about building your own siege weapon so
it's a ballista a catapult a trebuchet
or just a straight-up battering ram if
you wasn't so let's get into it it's
good anywhere so it's a physics-based
sandbox e-cell construction yet yes yes
if you've ever played a couple space
program which is a game about so
building your own spaceship this is more
about building your own medieval
contraption to destroy things so it's
the prequel to Kobol space it's pretty
cool that you are saying yes it's the
canonical prequel okay so what have we
got here you have a we have a melt in
the cube we're gonna destroy the mill
with this cube now if we just press buy
this cube is gonna do nothing because it
has no features so let's have a look at
Apollo terrible catapult so let's go
ahead and build off it with some blocks
just like this bill we did the basic
structure and we kind of want to think
about structural integrity right off the
bat so let's go ahead and make something
that it's uh just kind of fit together
pretty well so everything is made out of
wood and metal obviously
are there any kind of other materials at
present no I mean there are wings that
are made out of obviously some kind of
cloth perhaps medieval cloth medieval
cloth but basically wood and metal and
the wood burns that's gonna come gonna
play a bit like us so okay interesting
what we want to do is build a few
crossbars here okay like that now in
order to make it move we need some
wheels and wheels and just over here
let's go stick so the interface is
mostly just pointing click with keyboard
with camera control is that right I came
off the camera control you can rotate
with the mouse and you move the machine
with the arrow keys so if I just go
ahead and
for now oh cool Signac survivor mmm yes
you'll notice we can't actually steer
yet though and we need to actually add a
steering block to make that work now
oh I say I think that this is gonna be a
bit of tricky because the front wheels
so I'm gonna go ahead and move them
steering block here steering block here
I don't say create the axis for them -
yes you did it on that's so you need to
account for basically every single bit
of this contraption exactly I just ran
over chicken there as you can see and
you don't want to steer it too far
because you'll steer into yourself as we
did just there so yeah I mean like this
there's all kind of basic physics at
play yeah and you can see when I put it
down no one was a bit in the middle
that's not good that's gonna mean it's
gonna snap under its own weight
let's go ahead and add some braces here
so what accounting to do for every all
aspect of that's right yeah I mean you
know it's gonna be a masterpiece
so I mean here I was thinking that this
would be a simpler Kerbal space program
but it seems to be just as complicated
if not more complicated I guess so yeah
and you know the levels and the
objectives get much more complicated as
you go on as well so we now have a basic
structure we're gonna start putting
stuff on this okay what kind of what
kind of the machines you want to build
um something they can take down a
windmill easily something to take that
one not easy and I want to take down a
windmill I want a cannonball you want
cannon I want cannonballs well I've got
just the thing for you you're the
candidate let's just load up on the
cannon we don't even need to move
anywhere we can just see we two knots
um you know what you want some cannons
of fire off the shores no reason why
can't go wrong with firing straight up
no there's grace of this as well these
are counterweights Oh
are you gonna pull machine all right
let's go forward let's go forward this
feels like overkill you ready fire yeah
three two one I'm really liking this
game we're ready
okay that was cool that was cool okay so
so now you just progress the next level
and I just progressed to the next level
and as you can see our objective here is
to reach the in Sigma there's a go
different just destroying is like trying
to yes it's training you to use the
mechanical parts to actually make
something that moves now the problem
here is that you see these great things
those are bombs okay there's the bombs
and they are gonna blow me up because I
made a wood if I touch them so if we can
try and ease our way in here sorry mr.
Street oh no back up cheap no what do
you do oh god okay yeah I see so whereas
in that last hit you could've just made
you know a square with a bazillion
cannons on it yes you need to learn how
to use do it yes and as you can see and
I'm now stuck on this trees let's go
ahead and fire I can't be reckoned
dislodges yeah because you blow up the
bomb wow that was actually about a
stand-up cannon damn up cannons so as
you can see probably something that is a
bit thinner is gonna work here well I
got a better idea why don't we just
bypass everything by sticking some
propellers this is going to well I can
already tell now I'm not entirely sure
if that's gonna be enough to lift us
because we know a lot of cannons nope
so let's go and gotta get rid of those
Jeff cannons yeah but they're my
favorite they will be the death of you
now if we try and fly now you can say
we're just gonna tip over ourselves
because of all that why you need the
pounds on the bottom oh that's genius I
what about four holes at the back oh my
god that's that idea it's like a
hovercraft right isn't [ __ ] backwards
now they said it's being the wrong way
so it's bringing this way yeah
No look at reverse go reverse no I'm
actually flying Oh actually Siri me okay
it's not a good idea
Oh No definitely not we are
unfortunately gonna have to say goodbye
to these cannons so yeah I feel like I
know it carries over your last
contraption but if you like it
you need to start from scratch yeah you
need like a really thin you know cigar
shaped or or just explode your way - I
do the thing all right let's go ahead a
bat shell so it does it needs that is
like getting to the point the only
objectives you need don't need to have
your like structure intact or anything
like that you need to get this little
cube oh okay
that's the only one that triggers the
objective one say can we just put wheels
and that whole thing oh wow she never
thought of that that's a crappy yeah he
just gave this like alright we're gonna
walk yet it's tearing him real long real
and because that's made of like magical
metal okay so what happened there was I
had no wood into the steering hinge was
facing the wrong way so let's put a tiny
tiny of us make it a little like four
wheeled car yeah
yes or a bicycle all that's steering the
wrong way but who really need to pay
attention to which way things yes
is this the next pixar hero I believe so
like Wally's cousin alright let's go
ahead and Omo one more yeah yeah
some wheels inside here yeah that don't
I think this the two steering locks are
messing us off so let's go ahead and do
a walk out here
it's Jeremy blocking the front that keep
us upright mm-hmm should be a rock
should be right I guess I really really
like the little aesthetic of this game
yeah it's really nice it's a nice and
clean nice and creative so what oh
you'll we'll just fell off my wheel fell
off
what so we can still make it breathing
so okay so we're obviously not good at
getting from A to B no why don't we yeah
let's go blow some let's go some more
stuff up so is that only just the one
island at the moment there's only the
one island at the moment um they are
planning to add I think three or four
more islands there's also a sandbox mode
and later it appears you'll be able to
go to the moon as well the moon which I
believe is gonna have some different
physics at play which is gonna be really
interesting
hey this is working out this is like
it's raining down on I believe the
objective was to kill everyone and oh oh
come on mark come on do you have any
bits left you can steer no I just got my
one block hearts change you know what
we're gonna do we are going to load our
so grenades grenades guys are good idea
so what are they they like these are the
holders that are gonna hold flaming
balls there's my favorite favorite thing
in this game so far
flaming balls flaming balls okay so
that's working at welke this Bulls will
just keep on rolling that's wrong and
the fires can spread I love a good fire
spread
there we go success he's easy peasy
so it doesn't get way more complicated
than this I'm gonna say yes it does
actually yeah like for example this
steal and deliver yeah so you need to
pick up that stuff yeah you have this
item called the the grabber and the
grabber is something that some rat
hatches the physics objects okay so like
a yeah like a magnet pick me up singing
yeah basically I mean like if I go and
try and put a grabber on the front here
maybe the one on the ground maybe the
one on the ground
oh there we go there we go oh no yeah so
it's gonna be um kind of complicated
especially getting that large one out
there you like to grab is basically
basically two grabbers I mean ones can
be hair off
how about I feel like all of this front
weights up high is gonna be a bad idea
it's probably gonna be a bad idea but
you know we'll cross that bridge when we
get there it's gonna grab a thing it can
you um see your center of mass you can
do that
I believe that is right yeah okay so
it's really lies that's good it's a long
but it's it's forward so we want to
maybe can't wait look at that that's
beautiful it's like a majestic
mechanical draw yeah now the funny thing
is my thumb steering controls are
actually the wrong way around because oh
okay
the steering controls the wrong way
around because I put the steering hinge
on the wrong angle sorry it's very good
can we imagine Oh shame
you know II imagine the engineers of
medieval times just yes sing out absurd
contract interruptions like this I know
I mean I think about how much any
materials they would have have to go
through to actually get to the
conclusions we're getting to a man that
one would reason every spare time that's
true these days they could just do
whatever love it okay so that's really
good so now you've just good back yeah
it's not turning our is interesting
isn't something the front wheels
what's up the steering block in the
middle of the car that's good
what if I lines it up we put some
cannons and shot the ore into the object
is that a what you to do is have those
balls touch the glowy bit right exactly
so I'm just gonna move over here and
I'll just make the starting point my
name is Bobby it's not cheating it's
engineering
ah okay is that facing the wrong time I
shoot it's not face down if there's a
problem in this game just shoot it with
cannon yeah they see basically okay all
right okay you gonna be a count away
already
the counterweights actually meant to
only be for flying contraptions but you
know you can do whatever you want to do
everyone in this game that went terribly
it really did
yep if all else fails just add things
onto your options oh that's a big slice
and mold people it's more people up so
you can just like abysmally like destroy
your thing and still win the game
basically yeah I mean like the game
isn't trying to make you play perfectly
yeah
for example in this level we have to
destroy 80% in the power okay now the
only thing that can destroy things on
these kinds of shootin at us as well oh
and actually destroy me like I'm plating
it was something like that yeah we can
actually put some armor fighting on it's
a lot better yeah just destroy that wood
is that yeah that's how it works right
this one's gonna make us heavier but I
think it's something we need anyway so
let's see what our is there now
leisa protecting the wood okay
you know what would make it a really
good scorpion poison super flamethrower
it's gonna fire up words good reason oh
no there's an intersection so you can
only build within the constraints of
that yes of this cube so now far okay
hypothetically if I was an archer I saw
that thing coming my way
hi instantly reside not happening so
hypothetically can you just fill that
anti cube with like wall odds and wheels
yes yes you could it would take a fair
amount of time to do but there's really
nothing stopping you from doing that now
I got a bit of a plan okay my plan is to
launch ourselves up with
with flying sectional better moon and
you can move that more okay so you have
propellers we have propellers yes you're
not the only flying bit we have wings
stay we might well they don't flap on
their own but if you attach it to a
steering block you can basically guide
the driver why it's quite advanced and I
don't admire these know how it works
this really gives the prefect oh yeah
oops given every level in the works as
well absolutely now I'm just trying to
counteract the weight of our armor the
way about cannons let's see if this is
gonna take off oh I feel like we crushed
a guy with that cannon that's pretty
good look it's alright great we got some
pretty afraid yeah the dance of war yeah
I think you need a propeller on top of
the plating because there's nothing
helping those guys I'm totally sure
that's possible because oh wait no maybe
it's like gum and setting itself in yeah
in between okay so hypothetically can
you just build like a really really tall
at a pole and just fire me
yes so basically if you wanted to just
like just annual Tenon's upwards say put
your counters at a steering block yep
turn them oh wow they're firing from
quite far away they got one of those you
could you could basically
anything to anything you can attach
anything to anything within reason
sometimes without reason as well as you
can see we're gonna need you know a lot
more to get up there but I think we kind
of just need to build a little bit yeah
so I'm guessing there's two ways to
approach this is either to get your kind
of pole up on the cliff
yeah Paul just get it from down there
exactly and you know all we really need
to do and some fit one more walk in
there oh it does do everything right
let's go one loss for all shall we
that's the wrong way if this doesn't
work my grabber is still there as well
so just in case I get really close just
useless yeah so you can like obviously
save your you can save your contraptions
and work upon yet between any level as
well so you can just like have a grab a
machine or a cannon machine and just
bringing in as necessary absolutely yeah
you see this works too much goodbye to
Fabien Randall Albus Gregory and Tobias
sorry sorry gents it suppose only kicks
out a game with it no it's sort of just
a period I don't know around
okay so yeah yeah and it seems to be
taking the internet by storm it really
is like you know it's kind of like games
like couple space program games like
minecraft games like this we really
encourage all the creativity as you say
we're creative in our own special way
and the best thing about this is that
there's no wrong answer it doesn't say
do it this way let's do this however you
want
cool yeah that's awesome that is awesome
oh that's that was the seed that was
saving some bees and yet Ellie axis oh
yeah it's seven bucks
that is a bug it's only 7 bucks and it's
really fun at the moment it doesn't feel
like an early access game in terms of
like everything is polished and work
yeah it looks it's just this there's you
know more content coming right yeah more
say there's more sandbox mode that's
right yeah cool well thanks Dan it's
alright in exchange
you